good afternoon my name is crystal
Marshall and I am a junior here at
Hillsdale studying political economy in
Spanish and it is my privilege to
introduce to you this afternoon dr.
Steven Hayward dr. Hayward is the FK
warehouser fellow in law and economics
at the American Enterprise Institute and
a senior fellow at the Pacific Research
Institute for Public Policy dr. Hayward
holds a PhD in American Studies and an
MA in government from the Claremont
Graduate School and has been a visiting
professor at Georgetown University and
Ashland University
he writes frequently for numerous
publications including National Review
Reason the Weekly Standard the Claremont
Review of Books as well as a future
article recently published for a
commentary magazine entitled the liberal
misappropriation of a conservative
president his newspaper articles have
appeared in the New York Times The
Washington Post and The Wall Street
Journal among others he is the author of
several books including a two-volume
narrative history of Ronald Reagan and
his effect on American political life
including the age of Reagan the fall of
the old liberal order 1964 to 1980 and
the age of Reagan the conservative
counter-revolution 1980 to 1989 please
join me in welcoming dr. Steven Hayward
Thank You crystal and thank you ladies
and gentlemen for this extraordinary
turnout on what is a lovely fall
afternoon where I might be tempted to
enjoy some of the last days of sunshine
and warmth before the long Midwestern
winter settles in well let's begin this
way the education of any president or
statesman is a broad subject or can be a
broad subject and to bring some
illumination to the specific question of
Ronald Reagan's education I want to make
a simple and straightforward point which
is that scholars and citizens alike are
insufficiently attentive to the civic
education of modern presidents and
would-be statesmen and I don't mean
education in the formal sense but I mean
this in a deeper sense of the substance
of what is learned and known what have
the men women who lead us read and
contemplated in what setting and the
decisive question what difference does
it make can only be answered by knowing
what specific quality of mind marks out
those rare human beings on whom we
bestow the exalted title of statesmen
now there are many qualities and virtues
that go into that rich subject but I
want to concentrate here on the narrow
question of the connection between
education and the striking independence
of mind and unconventional imagination
that typify the greatest statesman of
ours or any age now our interest in the
education of presidents and presidential
candidates today seldom goes beyond the
surface to the universities attended and
the degrees taken our current president
and our last president last two
presidents in fact had graduate degrees
from Yale and Harvard which satisfies
the threshold of approval in comfort for
the Washington Beltway yet the contrast
between our previous president who had a
Harvard MBA and our current president
who has a Harvard Law degree begins to
suggest the problem and I don't just say
this because of their obvious
ideological differences it's not clear
for example that george w bush's MBA let
alone his undergraduate education at
yale which he seemed to regard with the
proper amount of insouciance was very
useful to him in the conduct of his
press
see as much as was more useful to him I
should say what was more useful to him I
think by his own statements was his self
study of history which consisted during
his present presidency of reading nearly
a hundred and sixty books a fact that
was seldom advertised to the media or
known to the public
our current president by contrast seems
almost willfully ignorant of American
history and political culture as when
for example he speaks of the 57 states
connected by the Intercontinental
railroad which may have even passed
through the historically Republican
state of Texas when presumably it was
not occupied by marine corpsman now
Ronald Reagan had a much sounder
attitude about the presumptive
credentialism of our time when told that
one of his prospective cabinet nominees
had a graduate degree from Harvard
Reagan said well we won't hold it
against him Reagan as you all know
hailed from tiny Eureka College in
Illinois a school that's even smaller
than Hillsdale and in that sense he is
what social scientists would call an
outlier in the data of presidential
education although many modern
presidents come from humble lower middle
class backgrounds in small towns Richard
Nixon Bill Clinton Jimmy Carter Dwight
Eisenhower and Reagan all beat that
description
nearly all who all modern presidents who
were elected to office come with either
Ivy League education or their clothes
equivalent combined with the close
association with what still deserves to
be called the eastern establishment this
is true even of Jimmy Carter a genuine
outsider figure who nonetheless attended
the Naval Academy at Annapolis and I
think it's striking that Richard Nixon
did penance for his undergraduate
education at Whittier College by
attending Duke law school and then
settling in New York as a Wall Street
lawyer as the path back to the White
House in 1968 rather than remaining in
California after his humiliating defeat
in the 1962 governor's race and so again
to take a sweep of things our last four
presidents were either Harvard or Yale
men both Roosevelt's were Harvard men as
was John F Kennedy
Herbert Hoover matriculated from
Stanford Calvin Coolidge from Amherst
William Howard Taft from Yale and
Woodrow Wilson had been president of
Princeton
although the less said about him in his
education the better I leave that to
hills dales good professor RJ post read
Oh
among presidents elected in their own
right is to say those presidents who
didn't become presidents somewhat by
accident by having been vice president
first namely Harry Truman and Lyndon
Johnson among presidents elected in
their own right you have to go all the
way back to Warren Harding to find a
president with such unestablished
educational credentials as Ronald Reagan
hence it was not surprising that when
Reagan was elected in 1980 that even
Roland Evans and Robert Novak two rare
conservative Washington journalists who
generally supported Reagan could write
at the time that quote no previous
President of the United States had so
bizarre preparation for political office
close quote my thesis today is that this
judgment even though it's from two very
good men is comprehensively wrong that
to the contrary Reagan was the best
prepared incoming president of the last
50 years and that not this preparation
consisted of much more than just as to
terms as governor of California or as
having campaigned twice for the Oval
Office
I think Reagan's success as a statesman
owes to one thing above all others his
complete independence of mind based on a
wholly unconventional education which
upon examination will be seen to have
been an idiosyncratic self education
Reagan was a very different kind of
conservative something we can say more
about later perhaps put simply there are
very few ways today aside from the
deliberate curriculum of Hillsdale
College where a prospective statesman
could acquire the kind of education
necessary for the demands of political
life in our time and especially the kind
of education that will convey an
original and independent cast of mind
now this is not really a new or original
theme but it is one that I say as I say
has been neglected Abraham Lincoln's
self education is legendary we know from
his biographies that he did extensive
reading of Euclid of Shakespeare
Blackstone Gibbon and the Bible and that
these other sources were central to the
formation of his legal and political
views and his
Rick but in those days in the early
1800s very few Americans attended
college or university and almost none
from the frontier where Lincoln grew to
manhood moreover and quite significant
for our purposes much of Lincoln's self
education continued long into adulthood
so much so that more than one biographer
noted that his law practice sometimes
languished because he was distracted by
his reading in more recent times as I've
suggested we tend to regard formal
university education as the whole of
education especially for our leaders but
the sad fact is that our prestigious
universities with a few limited
exceptions no longer provide the kind of
civic education that for example Calvin
Coolidge describes receiving an Amherst
in his autobiography if you never read
the autobiography of Calvin Coolidge one
of Reagan's favorite presidents remember
he describes receiving he describes in
particular the nature of his history
courses at Amherst in the hands of his
favorite professor Anson Morse for
example Coolidge wrote quote Washington
was treated with the greatest reverence
and a high estimate was placed on the
statesmen like qualities and financial
capacity of Hamilton but Jefferson was
not neglected the whole course was a
thesis on good government and good
citizenship those who took it came to a
clearer comprehension not only of their
rights and liberties but of their duties
and responsibilities close quote
similarly in philosophy Coolidge learned
from his courses quote that philosophy
revealed that man is endowed with reason
that the human mind has the power to
weigh evidence to distinguish between
right and wrong and to know the truth
close quote it's with that background
that Coolidge in his senior year won a
national prize for the best college
essay from the Sons of the American
Revolution in his essay title which
prefigured some of his extraordinary
speeches as president years later was
quote the principles fought for in the
American Revolution quote close quote
well Coolidge's education is almost
impossible today at most leading
universities except for the occasional
accident of an isolated sound teacher
usually hired by accident and barely
tolerated by the rest of the faculty
we're then to look for models of a
statesman's education in modern times
one place to look is one of Reagan's
favorite models alongside Coolidge and
that was Winston Churchill President
Reagan it turns out quoted Churchill
more often than all other American
presidents combined
as once challenged on that factoid by a
liberal who said well you know John if
Kennedy loved Churchill invited to the
White House on Churchill's last visit to
America in 1961 Churchill declined quite
sensibly and so I went back and and did
an extrapolation I took the Kennedy
Churchill quotation rate and projected
over a hypothetical two terms assuming
Kennedy had lived and served two terms
and found out that Reagan still beat him
so Reagan's still the champ no Reagan
didn't just quote Churchill's quips and
jests as a lot of people do
he cited Churchill and very substantive
ways and I think in fact Reagan's famous
axiom on foreign policy peace through
strength can be seen as derivative of
Winston Churchill's iron curtain speech
in Fulton Missouri in 1946 at Fulton you
may recall at the invitation of
President Harry Truman another largely
self-taught president who not
coincidentally regarded the Soviet Union
as an evil empire it was there at church
Truman's invitation at Churchill laid
out the theme that World War two could
have been prevented as Churchill wrote
without the firing of a single shot had
the Western democracies armed themselves
sufficiently and stood up to the
dictators resolutely as I say this is a
lesson Reagan took to heart in fact
Reagan appeared in Fulton in 1990 after
he'd left office and after the Berlin
Wall had come down to dedicate a
sculpture by Churchill's granddaughter
Edwina sans
where he noted in his remarks that quote
the road to a free Europe began here in
Fulton and it's not a coincidence that
Margaret Thatcher the Iron Lady recalled
the iron curtain speech when she made
that great comment about Reagan in 1990s
that Reagan had ended the Cold War
without the firing of a single shot now
as we know from Churchill's many
biographers Churchill did poorly as a
student in the lower grades of school
and only began to show his intelligence
when he reached Sandhurst
Britain's premier Military Academy
Churchill wrote in his autobiography my
early life that he quote enjoyed few
gleams of success at school like
Churchill Reagan always recalled his
formal education with a little bit of
diffidence with one important exception
a fragment from reagan's biography that
bears on an important aspect of his
character and that is his religious
faith and his sense of destiny can be
found in his encounter at age 11 with a
popular moral story of the time Harold
Bell writes book that printer of you
Dells the story is remarkably a
remarkably similar to Reagan's own story
in some ways the the book opens with a
scene of a boy standing over the
expiring body of his alcoholic father
and has seen similar to what Reagan
experienced himself with his own father
at about the same time the boy in the
story grows up moves to the big city
overcomes hardship and poverty to become
a tradesman that's the printer of the
title and then becomes politically
active urging his fellow citizens in a
speech to make provisions for the poor
among them now quite significantly I
think the speech in that book urges
private charity rather than public
assistance in part out of concern for
the dignity of the recipient quite
consistent with Reagan's own views about
what should be the limits of government
social safety net later in life the
story ends with the hero of that printer
view delsbo becoming deeply religious
acquiring a loyal wife and the city
voting to send him to washington d.c
coincidence maybe but Reagan said to his
mother after reading that book I want to
be like that man and Reagan still talked
about that book
decades later telling his biographer
edmund morris that readings right book
made him quote a practical christian he
said the book prompted his decision to
be baptized in his mother's church the
disciples of Christ and Reagan sent a
letter to Harold Bell Wright stata in
law while he was president saying quote
I had found a role model in that
traveling printer Harold Bell Wright had
brought to life he sent me on a course
I've tried to follow even unto this day
I shall always be grateful close
quote nonetheless Reagan was an average
student for much of his school in
college days about his college
performing at Eureka Reagan while he was
president said the following quote I let
football and other extracurricular
activities eat into my study time with
the result that my grade average was
closer to the c-level required for
eligibility than it was to straight A's
and even now I wonder what I might have
accomplished if I'd studied harder you
can see him grinning giving that line
right now we should recall here and the
answer the Churchill gave when a student
asked him quite late church's life I
think he was in his 80s when this
question was posed to him how should a
young person best prepare for a career
in political life Churchill's answer was
short and emphatic study history one of
Churchill's favorite axioms was the
longer you look back the farther you can
look forward on another occasion he
remarked quote a good knowledge of
history is a quiver full of arrows in
debate and on still another occasion he
said quote knowledge of the past is the
only foundation we have from which to
peer into and measure the future expert
knowledge however indispensable is no
substitute for a generous and
comprehending outlook upon the human
story with all its sadness and with all
its unquenchable Hope close quote now we
don't know how deeply Reagan read or
studied at Churchill Reagan's reading
habits were although prodigious not
something he recorded not something that
he wrote letters about detailing what it
was he was reading when more on that
story in a moment but I suspect he
studied Churchill more than we probably
know there were numerous of Churchill's
books on his shelves in his home in
Pacific Palisades and up at his ranch
above Santa Barbara where by the way
many of them are still there today but
there's a clear parallel between the
self education of Churchill and the self
education of Reagan if you know the
story of Churchill he went off to India
after getting out of Sandhurst at the
age of 22 although he was ambitious to
enter politics at some point but
significantly he wrote the following
quote I began to feel myself wanting in
even the vaguest knowledge about many
law
Spears of thought close quote in other
words Reagan recognized that his formal
education had been inadequate for a
would-be politician although I think
this was probably to his advantage
certainly it would be today as he wrote
quote the reader must remember that not
having been to a university I had not
been through any of those processes of
youthful discussion by which opinion may
be formed or reformed in happy
irresponsibility
so Churchill adds I resolved to read
history philosophy economics and things
like that it was a curious education
first because I approached it with an
empty hungry mind and with fairly strong
jaws and what I got
I bit secondly because I had no one to
tell me this is discredited you should
read the answer to that by so-and-so
there is a much better book on that
subject and so forth end quote
in other words Churchill had the
graduate students reading lists without
these often stifling guild mentality of
the Graduate faculty he formed his own
views reading these books by himself
sometimes four or five hours a day in
the in the hot Sun in the afternoon in
India when most of the other British
subalterns were napping so we do know
from Churchill's letters home and and
and also from my early life that for
example he read all eight volumes of the
Gibbons decline and follow the Roman
Empire
he read William Leki's history of
European morals he read a lot of
classical philosophers Plato's Republic
and symposium the works of Aristotle
scope and Howard John Stuart Mill Adam
Smith's Wealth of Nations he read also
Thomas Malthus Charles Darwin and on and
on and on one book we know he read but
of what he omitted to mention was
Machiavelli's Prince knowing this is a
book with a dangerous reputation he
omitted mentioning that and as publisher
published works Regan I like to suggest
went through a similar period of
self-education that resembles
Churchill's in some ways although it
happens later in his life than Churchill
there were two key phases of Reagan's
self education both involving a
combination of experience and study as
we know Reagan came to adulthood as an
admirer of Franklin Roosevelt and the
New Deal
though he used to delight later in
noting the ways the 1960s liberalism had
departed significantly from Franklin
Roosevelt's liberalism
still as late as the late 1940s Reagan
could still described himself as quote a
near hopeless haemophiliac liberal fancy
way of saying was a bleeding-heart right
but it was about this time that Reagan a
prosperous actor found himself in the
91% marginal income tax bracket that's a
phenomenon that turned more than a few
liberals into libertarians but in
Reagan's case he played out the logic of
the matter and realized the wider
effects it had on the on not just
himself but people in the movie business
you know cascading down to the directors
you know the camera people all the prop
people it affected the entire chain of
economic activity and so he came to
recognize the key axiom of what later
became supply-side economics namely that
incentives matter but more importantly
and secondly this was the period when he
saw the nature of communism up close in
person in the efforts of the Communist
Party to gain control of several
Hollywood trade unions now far from
being some paranoid misadventure of
McCarthyism as it's often portrayed this
was a very serious episode I mean we now
know from KGB files that the Soviet
Union actually spent several million
dollars trying to back labor union
infiltration efforts all over the
country but especially in Hollywood for
its propaganda value they didn't realize
all I had to do is wait till barbra
streisand in the 70s to achieve that but
be that as it may one of the many
mistakes that we were fortunate the
Soviet Union made in the 40s Reagan took
a leading role in opposing communist
influence and infiltration in the film
industry at some cost to his career and
some risk to his personal safety he was
threatened and carried a gun for a time
to defend himself and sterling Hayden
who was one of the infamous Hollywood
ten and an admitted member of the
Communist Party was asked to years later
what had stopped communism in Hollywood
and he said quote it was a one-man
battalion of opposition named Ronald
Reagan close quote so fast-forward 35
years later on the eve of his first
summit meeting with Soviet premier
Mikhail Gorbachev Secretary of State
George Shultz came to Reagan and during
some of the preparations for this and
passed along to Reagan that a lot of the
career people in the State Department
were
worried about how well Reagan would
match up with this young vigorous new
Soviet leader the conventional wisdom
was that Gorbachev would run circles
around him a week before the summit US
News and World Report quoted an unnamed
European diplomat saying quote Gorbachev
will swallow Reagan within half an hour
so Reagan said the Shultz don't worry
I've dealt with communists before in
Hollywood I know what they're like now
this was surely a less than reassuring
answer for anyone inside the beltway but
in fact as we subsequently know it was
Reagan who ended up running circles
around Gorbachev in every one of their
four summit meetings the second key
period of Reagan's political
self-education came shortly after
starting in the early 1950s when he came
host of GE theater as host of GE theater
may know some of the story
Reagan traveled the nation speaking to
GE plants in more than 30 states at one
little detail that's not widely known as
Reagan traveled in fact he had it
written into his contract that he would
travel by train to all these plants
mostly in the eastern United States from
his home in Los Angeles because he was
afraid to fly Reagan didn't step on an
airplane I think once for a 30-some a
year period in his life and that's a
fear he only conquered when his
political ambition made it necessary to
get on airplanes once again now his GE
traveling companion Earl Dunkel recalled
that Reagan spent much of those much of
the time on those long train trips
reading books and magazines and writing
his speeches looking back now Reagan
wrote in his memoirs I realized it
wasn't a bad apprenticeship for someone
who'd one day in her public life those
GE tours became almost a postgraduate
course in political science for me I was
seeing how government really operated
and affected people in America not how
it was taught in school he adds this
passage from hundreds of people and here
I think you get a sense of Reagan's
deepening appreciation for where and how
our Constitution has been subverted in
modern times from hundreds of people in
every part of the country I heard
complaints about how the ever-expanding
federal government was encroaching on
liberties we've always taken for granted
I heard it so often that after a while I
became convinced that some of our
fundamental
were in jeopardy because of the
emergence of a permanent government
never envisioned by the framers of the
Constitution a federal bureaucracy that
was becoming so powerful it was able to
set policy and thwart the desires not
only of ordinary citizens but their
elected representatives in Congress I'd
make a note of what people told me do
some research when I got home and then
include some excerpts in my next speech
now Reagan's detractors have long
assumed that someone presumably a second
wife Nancy or maybe Nancy's father had
talked Reagan out of his liberalism but
you can see I think why Reagan explained
how he did it himself in the 1970s he
said this eventually what happened to me
was because I did my own speeches and
did the research for them I just woke up
to the realization one day that I had
been going out and helping to elect the
people who have been causing the things
I had been criticizing so it wasn't any
case of some mentor coming in and
talking me out of it I did it in my own
speeches it was also during those those
touring days for GE that liberal that
Reagan began to experience what he
called the vindictiveness of the liberal
temper and sure enough the afl-cio to
which he had belonged as a head of the
Screen Actors Guild Union the afl-cio
branded Reagan a strident voice of the
right-wing lunatic fringe
sadly Reagan wrote I have come to
realize that the great many so-called
liberals aren't liberal they will defend
to the death your right to agree with
them now we don't know Reagan's precise
reading list during this important
period for reasons I mentioned before
but and and you know while he was
president we'd often hear stories people
would say he's reading in the following
very serious books about missile defense
about the Soviet Union and so forth
usually Reagan would only admit publicly
to reading the latest Louis L'Amour
novel and whenever his press office
wanted to put out a list of these
serious books he was reading to counter
the constant barrage that he was
uninformed and you know domme and all
those usual things Reagan's say no I
don't think we need to do that it was
part of his instinct that it's better to
be underestimated in politics but we do
know from the speeches he gave in the
50s and laters we can make out a few
things that he surely was reading back
in the 50s for example we know he read
Whitaker chambers great book witness
because Reagan could quote long passages
from memory 30 years later we can also
guess that he read Henry hazlit's
economics in one lesson
Hayek's Road to Serfdom and Milton
Friedman's capitalism and freedom we
know that Reagan was a charter
subscriber to National Review magazine
when it was founded in 1955 and we know
that he read the freedom of the freeman
of the periodical the foundation for
economic education and one detail I
think is quite significant Reagan was
fond of quoting the little-known 19th
century French classical liberal
economist Claude Basquiat Basquiat was
the inspiration for Henry hazlit's
famous one lesson in economics namely
that the art of economics consists of
looking not merely at the immediate but
the longer effects of any act or policy
so references to Basquiat sprinkle
reagan's speeches during those years
reagan quoted him once or twice by the
way in press conferences as president no
doubt causing the press corps to scratch
their heads about who he could possibly
be talking about along with another
obscure medieval arab economist eben
Khaldoon but you can I think see from
that reading all the themes that became
part of the famous speech on behalf of
Barry Goldwater's doom candidacy and
which was the template for reagan's
themes for the rest of his political
career now there's lots of good examples
of reagan's unconventional conservatism
and bold imagination at work but there's
one particular worth noting because of
its continuing applicability to our
current situation in the late 1970s
reagan took aim at a liberal proposal to
have the federal government guarantee a
job to anyone who wanted one another
words guaranteed full employment by the
government along side the ideal of
nationalizing health care this is at the
top of the liberal wish list and has
been since at least the 1930s if not
earlier in the 70s it was called the
humphrey-hawkins bill and it was the
subject of a major national national
debate at the time reagan devoted
numerous newspaper columns and radio
broadcast to attacking humphrey-hawkins
in the strongest possible terms his
economic argument was straightforward
and will sound very familiar namely
especially familiar in this age of
trillion-dollar stimulus bills namely
that by running a deficit the government
only taking money away from more
productive private-sector investment but
Reagan did end there he went much
further he went on to say for example
quote but there is much much more to
fear in humphrey-hawkins actually it
follows a pattern once used in Italy by
a fellow named Mussolini and then it was
called fascism close quote and that was
not Reagan's only invocation of that
incendiary term during his 1976 campaign
Reagan commented to Time magazine quote
fascism was really the basis for the New
Deal close quote
well the 1980 campaign Democrats
remembered this and brought it up Ted
Kennedy in particular made a point of
using this as an example of how extreme
Reagan must be to say something like
that
The Washington Post snapped to attention
did its duty into the front-page story
with the headline quote those old Reagan
isms may be brought back to haunt him
now if your conventional politician and
your conventional campaign consultant
the thing you want to do is to make this
story go away you want to say I didn't
mean it I was misquoted it was out of
context I was only joking it was a
thought experiment something like the
governor of North Carolina last week
after saying we should cancel elections
right what do you suppose Ronald Reagan
did not that to reporters he said he
defended the comment the reporters he
said quote anyone who wants to look at
the writings of the brain trust of the
New Deal will find that President
Roosevelt's advisers admired the fascist
system they thought that private
ownership with government management and
control like the Italian system was the
way to go and that has been evident in
all their writings close quote and this
was Reagan added as a nice little twist
this was long before fascism became a
dirty world a dirty word in the lexicon
of liberalism well now the Washington
Post they said in their story quote
several historians of the New Deal
period were questioned by the Washington
Post and they said they had no idea what
Reagan was referring to I'm not sure
who's more limit here the historians
they talked to or the Washington Post's
but once again Reagan is clearly on to
something and now by the way I mean his
comment is maybe politically imprudent
in a conventional sense and it was also
somewhat diss
with Reagan's favorable evocation of
Franklin Roosevelt in other contexts in
that campaign and you know it's just
dangerous territory to head into most
people think fascism means dictators and
stormtroopers funny uniforms and
persecution of minorities but you can
see that Reagan meant it in the precise
term of public control of private
resources and so to go back again to
another fragment from his attack on
humphrey-hawkins Reagan said quote the
annual plan would involve government
allocating government allocating
resources including labor
it creates national government machinery
for planning virtually every aspect of
American life projecting national goals
for production purchasing power and so
forth and why not there were liberals
the time saying that to humphrey-hawkins
would be the first step toward state
planning of the economy that was Felix
ROA Hatton that financier who helped
save New York City from its bankruptcy
well where'd Regan get this outlandish
idea well the most likely source was a
book well-known to Reagan Hayek's Road
to Serfdom in that book Hayek notes
quote indeed there is scarcely a leaf
out of Hitler's book which somebody or
other in England and America has not
recommended us to take and use for our
own purposes in 1934 the newly
established National Planning Board
devoted a good deal of attention to the
example of planning provided by these
four countries Germany Italy Russia and
Japan close quote
now with Reagan's phenomenal memory and
his imagination and his courage to say
something that no one else would say
including most other conservatives that
was all Reagan needed to press that
point and defend it
I can't imagine Howard Baker or George
HW Bush or Robert dole or any of the
other conservative Republicans at the
time being willing to make an argument
like that let alone to understand it and
this points finally to the most vital
lesson to be derived from a proper civic
education rather whether it's from a
rare institution of sound principles
like Hillsdale or on your own original
path I think when you find someone with
imagination and unconventional qualities
of mind and you combine that with
political courage what you usually see
before very long as a central insight
into the political problem of our time
ultimately people seek education whether
formal or informal precisely to get
insight and you know lots of people have
empty tankers of ink trying to
understand reagan's unusual habits of
mind people like to notice his his
pension for analysis by anecdote and
usually reagan's use of anecdote was
used as a means of denigrating his
intelligence although this conveniently
overlooks the fact that analysis by
anecdote is the method of Plato's
dialogues modern social science of
course tries to reduce thinking to an
orderly replicable process of formal
logic or quantitative models or the
context of a person's life but none of
this works right insight the philosopher
Bernard Lonnegan notes in his
Magisterial study of the subject is
reached quote not by learning rules not
by following precepts not by studying
any methodology insight is a function
not of outer circumstances but of inner
condition pivots between the concrete
and the abstract and passes into the
habitual texture of one's mind insight
is discovery not deduction it shares the
same element of genius that creates
great new art were there rules for
discovery than discoveries would be mere
conclusions were there precepts for
genius the men of genius would be hacks
close quote well Abraham Lincoln wrote
that all nations have a central idea
from which all its minor thoughts
radiate I think the same can be said of
great statesmen Churchill central
insight might be said to be that the
distinction between liberty and tyranny
is real and substantial now this may
seem trivial or obvious until we stop to
realize that modern value free social
science has gone very far into facing
the moral distinctions between different
kinds of nations or regimes as political
scientists put it and this has a long
pedigree in political science in the
relativist political science Thomas
Hobbes wrote in the Leviathan the
tyranny is merely king shipped miss
liked and if you go back to the book
shelves you will scour in vain to find a
modern political science textbook that
described the Soviet Union as a tyranny
more recently and something
wrote about a national review a few
months ago there's a whole parade of
eminent political scientists who made
fools themselves in recent years talking
about how moammar qaddafi of Libya had
been rehabilitated and that joined the
ranks of respectable world leaders until
he started shooting his own people a
number so large that it was no longer
possible to conceal the embarrassment of
this misjudgment
well reagan's central idea was a
variation of Churchill's and can be
summarized as the view that unlimited
government unlimited government is the
enemy of Liberty both in its vicious
forms like communism and socialism but
also in its supposedly benign forms like
bureaucracy and Reagan explained it this
way many times in his career
I think perhaps best in one of his
greatest speeches whether in my mind one
of his four or five greatest speeches
the one he delivered in 1982 in London
in the house of parliament this was the
speech that was more noticed for having
laid out the idea that it was communism
that was going to end up on the ash heap
of history where he committed some
rhetorical grand larceny and taking the
phrases of linen and turning them
against Marxism Leninism but in that
speech he also said this there is a
threat posed to human freedom by the
enormous power of the modern state
history teaches the danger of government
that overreaches political control takes
precedence over free economic growth
secret police mindless bureaucracy all
combining to stifle individual
excellence and personal freedom close
quote
notice the combination in the middle of
that sentence of secret police and
mindless bureaucracy secret police
referring to the most salient feature of
modern tyrannical regimes like the
Soviet Union mindless bureaucracy
characterizing oh the EPA in our
government to pick just one example I
think that that conflation of secret
police and - bureaucracy in that that
one sentence shows the harmony of
purpose of Reagan's own line between his
domestic and foreign policy and that the
problem of government power was not for
him a dichotomy of East and West but was
a continuum and here I think is the key
for understanding the unity of Reagan's
statecraft as well as a corrective for
the willful misinterpretation that
a lot of liberals trying to bring to
Reagan today liberals today try to argue
that the foreign policy Reagan was good
he made a deal that helped end the Cold
War but the domestic policy Reagan they
completely disapprove of of course
because his ideas are the ideas to put
very directly the tea party today but
this is a interpretive mistake of the
first order it's sometimes hard to make
the story out because the domestic
policy story it lacks the drama of the
foreign policy story it turns it's more
diffused there were more wins and losses
and more ties more issues and arguments
that were still playing out today or
above all as I put it Reagan never stood
in front of the Federal Trade Commission
or the Environmental Protection Agency
and said mister regulator tear down this
rule but that was an attitude that he
had so I have no doubt that we should
have that same attitude today in fact
you might go as far as to say that our
current out-of-control government
represents for us the challenge of
fulfilling Reagan's unfinished agenda
which means that we should think as he
thought we should read what he read
again and put it into practice thank you
very much and I look forward to taking
your questions or comments
well they're kind of be yeah there we
are we've got two students with
microphones so raise your hand and all
should spot you without my glasses and
the gentlemen the front row to kick us
off once you get one question go ahead
sir great and thank you so much mr.
Hayward and just a reminder there will
be a book signing in the outer lobby of
his book the age of Reagan the
conservative counter-revolution point
the microphone straight at you I think
it straight yeah yanked it you mentioned
the book the Road to Serfdom for
Friedrich Hayek that Ronald Reagan also
read since FDR we have been firmly on
the road to serfdom in a retrospect it
seems to me that Ronald Reagan one of
the greatest presidents we have had in
modern time was just a little bump in
the road to serfdom yeah yeah so so that
so that I was wondering and so the
Conservatives have proved to be impotent
to to resist the advancement of the
socialist agenda so what is it that both
have that makes them in the end that
makes the conservative impotent to
resist this sliding to serve them oh ok
interesting question I'm sorry yeah and
my own answer to that is it has to do
with a few of morality that both share
namely that man has no right to live for
his own sake your moral value comes from
your contribution to society to your
fellow man and and that that's supposed
to those in elba rights that we in fact
have no right to own them to our own
life let me take the first the first
through two-thirds of your of your
question and the architecture of it you
know Russell Kirk who used to hang
around these parts a lot used to like to
quote the line from TS Eliot that there
are no lost causes because there are no
gained causes now I'm not quite sure to
completely understand what Eliot meant
by that or what Kirk saw in it but but
the point I use that to set this up
if you look at the the ledger of things
you can make the case for you know
partial victories that have been
enduring I mean yeah true Obama wants to
raise taxes on everybody but there's a
very little chance he's going to get tax
rates back to 70% which they were before
Reagan came to office we're not gonna
make olden gold illegal we're not going
to reregulate we're relating some things
like banking and finance and it's all
going wrong but are certain areas of
progress that looked to be close to
irreversible
now one thought experiment to keep in
mind is that you might say you know what
winning the Cold War that's not a bad
thing to have accomplished and if you
did only that it seems to me that you
would celebrate the statecraft of Reagan
the converse of that thought experiment
is one I've often had is what you know
Franklin Roosevelt was able to do what
he did because he had two full terms and
then was able to stay in office during
the war and then be succeed you know
cement a lot of things in place
especially I think he appointed by the
time he left office eight of the nine
Supreme Court justices and they were all
bad right
and there's still way to answer this
question there's a thought experiment
what what might Reagan have accomplished
to be hadn't had the Cold War to fight
if he actually was able to spend all
eight years trying to accomplish
domestic reform my guess is he would
have actually accomplished more than he
was able to in some of the places where
he was frustrated he would have been to
have been able to break through now
that's only speculation on my part but
but is the circle back to the beginning
of no lost causes because there are no
gain causes I look at the Tea Party
today and it looks to me exactly like
almost exactly like these tax revolt of
the late 1970s with one difference the
tax revolt was really about high taxes
the Tea Party says it stands for taxed
enough already but an awful lot of the
energy the Tea Party comes to site as
for their interest in the Constitution
they are as I put it a populist
constitutional movement which James
Madison might have thought that was an
oxymoron on first glance and then and he
might have also taken some satisfaction
out of it on another level but here's
where I think you have to look things
over the long view I think the Tea Party
owes a lot of its inspiration to one of
Reagan's initiatives that we've almost
lately forgotten in the second term of
Reagan of Reagan's presidency mostly
through attorney general ed meese they
picked a big fight over the Constitution
you had ed meese in particular giving
speeches and writing articles on how we
need to return to original intent
jurisprudence annual the New York Times
of course had a fit two Supreme Court
justices gave speeches to rebut him and
all the law review is published symposia
and why the Reagan people are crazy
well the thing that's remarkable to me
about that is there was no polling data
saying that the public wanted to debate
about the Constitution there was you
know if you'd ask people don't open it
at survey what are the leading problems
in the country today you would have not
even gotten a rounding error below 1% of
people saying I'm worried about the
Constitution that was not on people's
minds it was on some conservative minds
but not on the general population and
now it is and now we're having this
vigorous debate partly prompted by
Obama's overreaching and I think we're
in a better position to carry forward
that debate because of that fight and
some of the other things that happened
around it like the federal Society and
so you know these these fights are never
they're seldom won completely we did
take our eye off the ball I'm for
rambling a little bit I've lately been
reading what I think is Hayek's best
book the constitution of Liberty and
there's some remarkable passages in
there that read like a commentary on the
Obama administration I'm astonished at
how well it matches up a 50-year old
book all right it's 50 years old this
year and one things he says the chapter
is reading yesterday was you know all
formal socialism is dying you know state
ownership or production but the new
welfare state kinds are actually gonna
be harder to fight I'm just paraphrasing
a little bit and then it turns out to be
exactly what has happened I think we did
get complacent after the Cold War ended
and thinking that liberalisation the
classical liberal ization was going to
sweep the globe and suddenly here we are
after 2008 saying what happened well we
do need to reappraise some that's so I
appreciate the question it's a hard one
and a good one and other people will
give different answers than I did
someone else let's go right there in the
middle and I gotta get my peripheral
vision going here and students need to
step up and ask those good youthful
questions from people who didn't see
Reagan firsthand
thank you so much for your speech
tonight I'm looking to the example of
Ronald Reagan what can you suggest to
students today who are looking to
further their own civic education well I
mean I'd reiterate one things I
suggested in my talk which is read what
he read you're already doing that
Hillsdale I mean you know I don't I
don't I don't lack for confidence in the
curriculum here at Hillsdale one thing
that I think I actually say this the
politicians who say they Reagan is their
hero his study his speech making style
and I don't just mean his delivery
that's important but also how he
structured his speeches and how he kept
them shorter for the most part I
actually went back and looked at this I
looked at Reagan's State of the Union
speeches which usually came in about 40
to 45 minutes and were about 4,500 words
and he gave them pretty quickly and you
know we like the applause and everything
but and here's the point I should get to
the wreck point Reagan one of these
Reagan learned from show business was
always leave your audience wanting more
the average politician thinks I'm not
leaving the room till I've told
everybody everything I think that's a
huge mistake I think if you internalize
in your political communication that's
show business rules of Reagan you'll be
better off oh so in the state of the
union's Bill Clinton routinely pioneered
the 6502 7,000 word Castro asked State
of the Union speech and it's been that
way ever since I'm even George W Bush
kind of did that so in other words you
know leave your audience wanting more
the variation that is less is more and
then there's the the sort of the
rhetorical structure of his speeches is
worth studying I have to say I get very
frustrated when I hear politicians you
know conservative politicians say
Reagan's their hero and I want to sort
of slap them upside the head and say
well then do your homework and pay
attention to how we did it now these are
some of the things we heard of on the
surface you know the substance is
equally important or more important but
you know they go together and Reagan had
an instinctive understanding of that
again partly acquired from a show
business career partly as I suggest a
little bit partly from you know going
and speaking to audiences on political
subjects for 10 years before he was ever
a candidate almost nobody gets that kind
of
and so I would say finally it's worth
learning how to talk on your feet if you
want to be a not necessarily an elected
official but someone who wants to
participate in public life and by that I
mean show up at your local County
Supervisors meeting or County Commission
meeting when they're doing something bad
and you have the three minutes are in
the open mic thing when you can deliver
a three minute beatdown that really gets
the point across that's a great skill to
learn how to do so you know Speech and
Debate drama for that matter that's
worth learning to and Reagan would tell
you that I think have you asked him
someone else here yeah I'm gonna wing
somewhere you get the gentlemen here at
his hand up yeah
thank you dr. Berger for your
presentation
my question is Tyson with a speaker
yesterday at this time Ronald ray das
has a topic of Ronald Reagan and
communism and Hollywood right and I
didn't get a chance to give him this
question so I'm going to give you the
question came in your opinion Ronald
Reagan's evolution from a liberal to a
conservative what impact or was that a
catalyst for his first marriage failure
to Jane Wyman well you know both Reagan
and Jane Wyman both their credit never
really talked much about you know their
personal life and what led to all that
there you know there's sort of little
bits and pieces have floated out over
the years and they're sort of one
interesting little wrinkle honest toward
the end I think is funny your Reagan was
beginning to get deeply interested in
politics he was starting I think he
started you know he talked about when he
was in the service you know Isaiah army
captain in world war two he said that's
my first experience of inefficient
bureaucracy and realizing that the
government could behave pretty stupidly
so he can't see it as a service but it
was in Hollywood and I Ron ray - may
have told you some of these stories
yesterday you know he went to some of
these meetings of these supposedly
liberal groups Popular Front track
groups and he realizes people aren't
liberals they're communists this is
they're lying to us and that was very
bracing to him and so he gets deeply
interested in politics and I think Jane
Wyman was completely uninterested in
this
and so I think they just grew apart now
I think what's interesting about this is
it fast forward 30 years to when he's
president and there's a real lesson how
can either guy is you know Calvin
Coolidge's to tell the story you know
silent cow right he was anything but it
was a very eloquent man as we know but
how he got the reputation of silent Cal
he kind of explained it one day he said
most people who come into the Oval
Office to see the president are they're
trying to get something they shouldn't
have and he said I find if he just sit
very still like a cigar store Indian
after about three minutes then run out
of gas and leave you can imagine by the
way how unnerving it would be to be in
the Oval Office of the president staring
at you not moving and we'll heart of
barely blinking right you'd get like
well that would never work for a guy's
gregarious as Ronald Reagan so with that
in mind remember the complaint rate
about Reagan
so sorry I'm telling us a lot of order
but in the late 40s and time it was
divorced people said Reagan won't shut
up about politics it's all he talks
about he's becoming a bore so in
Washington Tip O'Neill oftens
Republicans would go to see him you know
in Reagan's diary he complains more
often about Republicans and Democrats
his own Republicans not backing him up
on the things he wanted to do
interesting sub story that I think I
first-person really tell this more in my
book about him and so even he a Bob Dole
comes to work him over about increasing
taxes and the garius Reagan he doesn't
want to argue about this stuff it makes
life unpleasant right so what would he
would tell him Hollywood stories they
come in and he tell him some Hollywood
story that heard before and then you
know some aid would come in say I'm
sorry mr. president I know move on to
your next meeting so all these people
will all be smart Washington people will
walk out of the room and say darn that
Reagan we can't get him to be serious
all he talks about is Hollywood and
tells us jokes and stories it shows what
a none serious guy he is now so here's
the Reagan from four years before was
obsessed with politics and the Reagan's
gonna tell Hollywood stories to
politicians who's being had here
they never figured this out they never
figured out there being had every time
was Reagan's defense mechanism and it
doesn't quite get that some of the
questions about his personal life or the
various people have different theories
about that they're sort of intriguing
and interesting but by the way one thing
I say in my book is that Reagan is a
throwback to an earlier time of people
who didn't think it was their duty to go
on Barbara Walters and spill out all
their introspections of the world and
that's another thing to like about him I
think so someone over here have a hand
up I haven't looked over that way much
let's get the gentleman on the aisle
over here yeah on the others right over
there on this side thank you for coming
this next election won't be my first
opportunity to vote and in light of what
you said about formal education and self
education is there any comment that you
could make about the candidates that
have stepped forward up to this point
hmm
well boy want me to play pundit I'm yeah
I mean them I don't see I don't see that
same originality of mind and I don't
think anybody I mean I mean there's
certain people that certain ones have
certain virtues that I kind of like you
know Herman Cain is interesting I think
he sort of formed his the school of
experience I think it would be better I
think if he'd held some kind of public
office before he runs for president but
that's a little thing I've always been a
big defender of Sarah Palin because she
reminds me of Harry Truman someone who
was self-taught and I remember the you
know P she went to three colleges like
you know and the three of the wrong
colleges of course that's one of the
great complaints about her and I thought
oh that means she's you know I like that
and you know right now if you ask me for
my prognostications I think Romney's
gonna win the nomination just because
he's the best organized he's been
through this before but he looks way too
conventional to me he's sort of the
presidency as conceived by McKinsey
Consulting another you know this time we
really will have an MBA presidency
unlike George Bush's and that doesn't
give me a lot of confidence and Perry I
haven't really looked at close enough
haven't read his book I probably should
you know Bachmann's kind of interesting
she's pretty fearless and shown some
real spunk I think made some mistakes I
think too but yeah I mean the sorry
governor Christie's not gonna run I was
announced today if you hadn't heard it
he's not gonna run I think he's an
interesting guy and it's time for a
large iced I kept joking for months that
my ideal ticket was Christie and John
Bolton I didn't care what order I want
to bring back girth and facial hair and
in the executive suite
so yes where there are any disadvantages
to Reagan's being self educated
hmm any disadvantages to Ragan being
self educated none that well I think
that certain mistakes he made and
certain kinds of weaknesses you can make
out about him really art the result of
his education formal or informal Regan's
one maybe not his only weakness but you
don't see one weakness but one weakness
that Reagan had which is fairly common
with leading statesmen like him is they
tend to overestimate the force of their
own personality you know Churchill used
to say if I could just be at the end of
World War two he would say if I could
just die in alone with Stalin once a
week we could avoid all the supposed to
were trouble we see coming at us which
is surely wrong right that's a
completely amiss a misjudgment of the
depths of Stalin's evil and an
overestimation of the your own force of
your own personality and Reagan used to
say something similar to that you know
he used to say and as throughout his
presidency before he started having
summit meetings with Gorbachev gosh if I
could just get one these Soviet leaders
up in an airplane and flying around
American cities and explain our country
to them they'd realize how stupid their
system was and his aides would sort of
roll their eyes and I really thought
that and I could see that a lot of other
other folk you know Bill Clinton thought
he could bring peace to the Middle East
if he just sat long enough with Yasser
Arafat in 2000 and you know they're they
almost deserved each other but that's
another anyway but that's not an
educational thing that that's sort of a
a sort of character trait that you often
find in people like that and as
witnesses go that's not the worst one in
the world in Reagan's case there may
have been a certain that that's part of
the self confidence he had throughout
his whole life he was very confident in
the acting profession even when I went
badly for him and had to sort of change
change what his act was and so forth so
no I don't you know he was uh he was a
smart guy who got stuff and then
concealed from us how smart he was
anyway
we got time for one or two more look at
the gentleman right here in the middle
and then I'll try and get away in the
back I'm not looking whether you go
there and look at the guy in the back
I'll try and squeeze two more in here
and an answered more briefly
let's say recently there have been some
books written about President Reagan's
religious faith and how it influenced
some of his activities I was wondering
if you could tell us something about his
religious training and and how his
beliefs were formed yeah that really is
a good question for Paul kanga or one of
the other authors who've really zeroed
on that closely what I observed this is
another area of Reagan's life that he
kept a little bit private I mean one
thing is you can tell about him is that
he had you know knew the Bible because
he go off and quote like Lincoln he
could biblical phrases which show up in
his impromptu comments as well as his
set-piece speeches and in his private
letters a number of his private letters
talked about how he believed that the
Bible was the Word of God and true from
beginning to end didn't believe the
modern you know fancy interpretations
and whatnot there were the frequent
references and maybe frequent too strong
a word but there were the occasionally
in public he would say which really
unnerved a lot of people you know these
may be the days that see Armageddon you
know as the biblical prophecy goes and
this would really upset people who said
this guy is gonna have his finger on the
button and there's one letter in
particular to Peter Hannaford from 1983
where he says you know I look at what's
going on now and all our troubles in the
Middle East and everything else is I
really have to wonder if we think we
aren't living in the end times and any
yeah it's next sentence please don't
quote me on this he knew this was a you
know a dicey thing to say I will I did
ask
I forget why I asked ed meese about this
or why came up a conversation but in
addition to Reagan's sort of private
sense that I had served alluded to
earlier in other contexts he was also
put off by the way he thought Jimmy
Carter had abused his religious faith
and wore it so much on his sleeve and
one of the grunion
you know sort of unseen Corrections at
Reagan Wanda brings to try and bring
that back into some kind of proper
bounds and so Reagan would make lots of
you know general references to religious
faith you know god Bless America and so
forth at the end of his speeches but he
he thought Carter had gone too far with
that and that's sort of another
interesting and there's something he
never said anybody never
down a letter but something that ed
meese told me he thought was I think
maybe me said Reagan had said that to
him a couple times as they were getting
up in the campaign of 1980 let me take
the gentleman in back and then we're out
of time
I thank you very much dr. Hayward I was
just wondering what effect you think
Reagan's experience at Eureka College
had on his self education that he'll
still we talked about learning how to
read and how to think and we'll probably
read a lot more once we get out of here
but yeah we learn how to do that yeah
the great quaint if you'll heard the
question it was you know how did
Reagan's education at Eureka College you
know help his subsequent self education
career and and I think the tie in there
is and actually I'm glad you asked that
because I wanted at some point to say I
mean the point of a really good
education formal education like you get
at Hillsdale is that you're not finished
when you're done here I mean you'll be
finished with your degree but that's in
some ways at the beginning and it equips
you then to go out and learn more and
now you'll have the foundation to learn
things well and learn them sensibly on
your own or in graduate education or in
a profession or so forth you know I'm
not sure we ever have anyone's ever been
able to find out what the actual
curriculum was at Eureka College you
know what books were on the reading
lists that Reagan took apparently none
of his college essays are very few of
his college essays survived anywhere but
one salient aspect this Reagan graduates
from Eureka College in 1932 so at the
beginning of the Great Depression right
or beginning of the Great Depression
beginning of the New Deal
well Keynes general theory doesn't come
out - what 1935-36 Reagan learned he was
an economics major he learned his
economics before Keynes and that's why
when you finally got the challenges to
Keynesianism in the 70s really matured
you know supply-side economics but also
the the critiques of people I can rehash
that and Milton Friedman made it was an
easy sell for Reagan you know Richard
Nixon said we're all keynes ian's now at
the moment kim jainism was about to
expire
again the product of a conventional
establishment education right
and Reagan immediately saw the wisdom of
this and was able by the way to RER tick
you late in his own words and add to it
in you know it's persuasive power that's
one of the great things about Reagan is
you know you give them a technical idea
there's some people who talk about how
they'd send him a draft for a Saturday
radio address about the you know why
they need to refund the World Bank
because the one story Peter Wallison
tells and it's all very technical
Treasury Department stuff and Reagan
rewrites it into a paragraph and a half
and it's just these people to say we
can't believe how clear this is and how
much better it is than what we provided
he could do that sort of thing there's
another great story he was on the
commission in the mid 70s that Ford set
up was the Rockefeller Commission to
sort out the problems of the CIA after
the Watergate scandals and they're
having a meeting one day where they're
fighting about something and Reagan just
sitting here watching and they're all
thinking why doesn't he ever say
something Reagan finally raised his hand
and he'd been scribbling on his yellow
pad and says here fellas like you'd say
that right I've written two paragraphs
here on this problem and he reads it
aloud and they all look at each other
across the table and say that's what we
want to say well a lot of sources for
that sort of ability but certainly the
one particular point I think we can be
confident about is that his pre
Keynesian economics training was served
him very well when the post Keys lien
moment arrived in the late 1970s and
1980s so thank you for that question
thank you all very much for coming